le débat sur france 24 27e jour de
guerre en ukraine on va s'intéresser ce
soir aux sanctions contre la russie et
en particulier contre les oligarques
russes de yachts appartenant au
milliardaire russe roman abramovitch ont
accosté dans le sud ouest de la turquie
selon les médias turcs la turquie qui
n'appliquent pas les sanctions
occidentales
les images des yachts immobilisé à la
ciotat dans les ports d'hambourg ou
encore de barcelone tournent en boucle
sur les réseaux sociaux ils sont devenus
le symbole de la traque aux avoirs de
ces oligarques russes
877 hommes d'affaires et politiciens
russes sont visés par les sanctions de
l'union européenne
longtemps épargné par les sanctions les
milliardaires proche du président
poutine sont désormais dans le viseur de
l'europe mais aussi des états unis pour
leur soutien apporté au kremlin alors
qui sont ils ces oligarques russes quels
sont leurs liens avec vladimir poutine
sont ils influent quel est finalement
l'effet des sanctions occidentales les
sanctionner peut-il dissuader poutine de
poursuivre la guerre eh bien on va en
débattre avec mes invités j'ai le
plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés thierry
wolton bonsoir essayiste spécialiste des
sociétés communistes et post-communiste
votre dernier livre penser le communisme
et c'est aux éditions grasset bienvenue
à vous également en face de vous sergueï
mironov bonsoir ancien officier
supérieur du kgb coauteur de l'éclaireur
du recrutement à la formation l'histoire
vraie et stupéfiantes du seul espion du
kgb à avoir intégré l'ena pour infiltrer
l'administration française et 7 aux
éditions un hymne road merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce soir également
bienvenu olivier dorgan bonsoir avocat
spécialiste des sanctions économiques au
cabinet ashurst bienvenue à vous
également en face de vous sarah brimbeuf
responsable du plaidoyer grande
corruption et flux financiers illicites
chez à transparency international france
bienvenue également qui révolte on va
démarrer avec vous vous avez écrit sur
l'union soviétique bien avant d'ailleurs
qu'elle ne devienne la russie lors ces
oligarques sont nés avec l'effondrement
de l'union soviétique c'est y est l'air
y est in comment est ce que vous pouvez
les définir aulas c'est beaucoup fin à
l'époque à l'inversé peu en vérité va
c'est pas en vérité donc ça date de
cette époque oui oui il y en a qui ont
disparu il y en a qui se continue
abramovich était des départs par exemple
mais aujourd'hui il est toujours là
berezovski qu'étaient les départs n'est
plus là il a été liquidée on a été
liquidés ou non avec poutine bon bref ou
comment ce même dans ces années 90 et du
mans à l'effondrement du système pour
une raison simple c'est que
enfin la russie tente une situation
catastrophique
elle signe veut faire des réformes il se
il s'entoure d'un certain nombre de
spécialistes qui sont plutôt libéraux au
niveau économique et qui pensent qu'il
faut libérer l'économie mais sauf
qu'évidemment après après 70 ans de
peut-être de planification et c'est très
lourd et donc une choisissent c'est ça
qui va faire la fortune de certains ils
choisissent de distribuer des actions au
peuple c'est quand même derrière ce
qu'il très bien que c'est une très belle
situation à pleaux départ aux russes aux
russes en lisant voilà nous avons des
perles magnifique des bijoux magnifique
et nous vous donnons des actions
évidemment les rues si ça pays pensaient
à l'époque plutôt à se nourrir que des
actions quitté potentiel en plus parce
qu'elles rapportaient rien et donc
beaucoup ont vendu ses actions pour
dépend des bouchées de pain à des
oligarques
c'était pas des oligarques l époque
c'était la mafia
c'était à la fois la mafia des gens du
parti des gens du kgb qui avait un petit
trésor de guerre qui avait été mis bien
de côté en suisse ou dans d'autres
paradis fiscaux avant la chute et qui
avait l'argent ils ont acheté ça est ce
qui fait que certains se sont retrouvés
avec des actions énormément d'action /
10 / des sur des entreprises qui avaient
bu qui veut aller beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent donc des secteurs pétroliers
qu'elle est c'est donc vraiment puisque
c'est comme vous le savez la russie est
une vraie est un pays très riche en
matières premières et donc quelqu'un
comme abramovitch a ce moment la rue
abbey là où il a eu ses il a eu sa
partie alors ces gens là étaient
forcément lié
ce milieu si je puis dire bon quitte à
phyllis il a défini entre entre kage
beast dont des agents du kgb du parti
des missiles et des mafias qui sont très
importants qui était existait bien avant
la mafia est est toujours infiltré dans
l'économie y compris à l'époque
soviétique
donc et qui est enfin comme toutes les
mafias de l'argent et donc je voulais
cette espèce de groupe comme ça bon mais
poutine à l'époque n'existe pas abouti
mais étaient-ils au kgb à l'époque il à
l'ancien en tout cas il est il est à
saint pétersbourg 1 il travaille avec le
maire huile et papy sac particulièrement
des trafics dans le port portuaire et
c'est bon et il commença sur une petite
fortune d'ailleurs c'est comme ça qu'il
a acheté une villa à biarritz à l'époque
un nous sommes dans les années 90 bon
mais c'est un petit personnage dans tout
ça c'est pas un grand ligue arc du tout
bon il va arriver au pouvoir pour des
raisons plus compliqués qu'ils ont
peut-être pas l'occasion de le dire mais
parce qu'on va apprécier chez lui son
sens du devoir son sens de la discipline
son sens de l'ordre donc qui fait qu'on
va l'amener pouvoir après à la fin
delsinne pour remettre de l'ordre mais à
l'époque ils n'étaient pas programmés
c'était une marionnette on pourrait dire
les progrès pour se dire s'il allait
être voilà c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est finalement la fonction a fait
l'homme en fonction fait l'homme sa game
aux lego virna fort vous vous êtes un
ancien espion soviétique et russe vous
avez espionner la france avant de
devenir vous réfugier ici au début des
années 2000 vous le racontez dans votre
livre alors quel est le poids politique
des oligarques aujourd'hui qu'à leurs
relations avec le kremlin ont participé
avec vladimir poutine au début c'était
les gens qui comme ça a été racontée par
thierry wolton cesser les gens qui
étaient autour de pouvoir aux côtés de
pouvoir et donc il avait énormément
pouvoir côté à côté tout le règne de
près estime par exemple moi je connais
quelqu'un personnellement la lumière
protéines qui est un camarade d'études
qui est terminée la même école que moi
donc qui est devenu milliardaire et en
1996 il a aidé moi eltsine à reconquérir
le pouvoir pendant sa de son deuxième
mandat et d'oublier le signe de l'art
compenser et il est devenu premier
adjoint au premier ministre donc c'est
un peu la génération entre guillemets
les oligarques yasin c sans danser ça et
est donc à ce moment là si vous voulez
il avait vraiment le pouvoir parce qu'en
fait il y sauter d'un poste de
milliardaires un poste gouvernemental
d'un poste de ministre un poste de
milliardaires et du coup on pouvait les
appeler vraiment les oligarques poutine
arrive
en 2000 et il veut mettre de l'ordre
dans tout ça en fait en gros il dit que
je vais mettre de la distance entre le
pouvoir politique et le pouvoir
économique est en fait il dit je vais
les mettre à la même distance du pouvoir
mais en gros en sti triche pas ce qu'il
veut devenir le sol oligarques dans le
pays il deviendra avec ses amis les
anciens du kgb donc il va faire en sorte
de tree hill
sorte de tri par exemple quand un code
en cause ce qui va le mettre en prison
goussinski va partir en israël
berezovski va s'exiler à londres et donc
il va poursuivre un certain de personnes
qui n'ont pas compris les noëls les
règles de jeu pour l'exemple pour
l'exemple pour l'exemple pour pour leur
donner en fait en gros le motif de
poutine c'est vous faites les affaires
pas la politique la politique c'est moi
qui le fais et donc celui qui s'amusera
à faire la même chose qu'eux souligne
chine donc en fait à s'entremêler les
affaires la politique lui sera puni et
il donne quelques exemples donc bien
évidemment il punit un certain degré de
choses donc khodorkovski c'est assez
lent brûler l'emblème et qui sait il est
donc il faut le dire aux téléspectateurs
au royaume uni malik rose au club ce
qu'il était il était en prison il a
passé que l'on disait en dix ans dans
l'ambiance et une fois lorsqu'il est
sorti de prison il a
en allemagne et puis maintenant mettons
à londres mais le principe en fait c'est
que actuellement on se retrouve avec un
système où les algues les oligarques ne
joue quasiment plus aucun rôle politique
ça veut dire autour de poutine ya
toujours les gens qui sont qui sont
milliardaires il ya toujours des gens
qui font les affaires souvent ils
prennent les fils à papa ça veut dire le
fils patrushev le fils bortnikov enfin
mail et les fils des responsables des
hauts responsables politiques et des
services spéciaux mais
putin les vois plus comme comme des
puissances le craignent manière faut-il
absolument absolument au day d'ailleurs
en fait suffit de regarder l'interview
donnée par friedman qui disait que si
vraiment on alpha group a pardonnez moi
je le prends parce qu'on a on a
justement on va aller on va les voir
pour bien comprendre on a mis mirail
friedman donc il dirige alpha group a on
va voir 12 milliards de dollars de prêts
c'est ce qu'il pèse 1kg autres aven qui
dirige alpha bank group
4 milliards de dollars à peu près alors
que font partie justement de cette
deuxième si l'on peut dire un poteau le
gâchis yalcin
ils ont réussi à se sauver les
capitaines des groupes publics ça ces
roches justement alexeï miller vie qui a
été vice-président lui de l'énergie donc
lui il a fait de la politique avec
poutine puis ça c était au gouvernement
cette semaine par exemple igor ces
voix-là igor setchine ont là aussi qui a
été vice premier ministre dans le
gouvernement de poutine également à l'or
lui on l'appelle le croquemitaine du
kremlin encore on peut on peut leur a
alors un de leurs données en temps ce
sobriquet qu'on veut mais tout est en
tout cas on voit à peu près où il agit
alors voilà alors après prigogine les
amis personnels du chef du kremlin
d'après ce que j'ai vu aussi alors
nikolaï tokarev qu'est devenu patron du
groupe
sergueï tchemezov les
titres
c'est bizarre mais on a un peu plus
effectivement que ce que je cite et puis
évidemment il y en a qui est très connu
forcément c'est roman abramovitch vous
le disais que vous le disais que lui
fait partie des tous premiers qu'il a
réussit donc à se frayer un passage
secret qui s'est tenue bien et les
quarts après il a compris qu'il a fait
c'est un ferrailleur qui a fait ses
affaires ailleurs au royaume uni en
l'occurrence et donc tous vous dites
craignent vladimir poutine oui c'est ça
ça a changé enfin en fait le truc c'est
que est-ce que vieillir poutine les
consultent parfois mais il est peut les
consulter et mais de toute façon c'est
lui le maître en fait et il peut les
approuver au kremlin venir lui rapporter
des choses il venait leur demande aussi
de paix de financer un symptôme
d'opérations qui ne veut pas financés
par le budget de l'état donc en fait
c'est aussi ça ça reste aussi les bandes
de brillantes et lycées c'est une forme
de clientélisme intéressant chez pucci
poutine si je puis dire c'est une espèce
de filet avait d'amitié je plaisante pas
dire que les gens qui l'entourent vraie
amitié oui parce que des gens qui
avaient qu il rit pour les premiers
millions ou si je puis dire à à saint
pétersbourg et un groupe de
saint-pétersbourg est très important et
c'est vraiment eux d'ailleurs qui sont
dans certains qui sont dans ces postes
parmi ses réglages en a parlé un
ménisque à la coopérative de la
guadeloupe c'est ça et ceux qui sont
vraiment autour de poutine
qui sont ces conseillers et avec qui il
a des il va à la chasse enfin il va à la
pêche ses amis quoi olivier doran 877
personnalités russes ont sanctionné par
les européens tous ne sont pas
oligarques bien sûr j'imagine alors
castrais aisée et russe en quoi
consistent ces sanctions puisque vous
êtes le spécialiste est ce que ça veut
dire on gèle c'est un gel de leurs
avoirs financiers et de leurs biens mais
ce n'est pas une saisie il ya une
distinction entre les deux c'est ça
c'est tout le débat dans lequel on les
hommes politiques se sont se sont
engouffrés depuis quelques semaines les
mesures de gel quand on les regarde de
strictement sont des mesures qui visent
à rendre les biens et les actifs
financiers indisponible durant toute la
durée du des sanctions donc c'est
vraiment on est on ne touche pas au
patrimoine c'est-à-dire qu'on a on
interdit aux oligarques de vendre leur
villa on interdit à l'égard de vendre
leur bateau est une question qui se pose
sur savoir si oui ou non ils ont le
droit d'y et de jouir de leurs
propriétés ça c'est un point assez rare
une question ils ont pas ce qu'il
pourrait avoir le droit de jouir de
cette une question idiote si on
distingue en fait venir quand on aime
les mesures sont mises en oeuvre en fait
historiquement les banques et les
chaises et des sociétés de gestion
s'intéresser principalement avoirs
financiers parce que c'est simple on les
traces et on les jalons les blocs il
compte encore des comptes en moment
faire détester portefeuille de titres
par contre pour tout ce qui est actif
immobilier ou tableaux de maîtres ou
bijoux ou autres c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué parce qu'on doit mettre en
oeuvre la puissance publique c'est à
dire qu'on doit venir ce que ce soit les
bateaux des douanes que ce soit des
officiers de police judiciaire en fait
on doit venir poser des cds sur une
maison doit venir demander à la
capitainerie d'emport d'intervenir si un
bateau qui te paraît c'est pour cette
raison-là que jusqu'à aujourd'hui on
avait très peu d'exemples voire
quasiment pas d'exemple de mise en
oeuvre de mesures de gel des avoirs qui
portait sur des biens et donc la
question de savoir si oui ou non les
gars peuvent jouir il ya débat il ya
encore un débat est ce qu'ils peuvent ou
non sachant que de toute manière ils
sont interdits de séjour sur le
territoire européen donc sauf avoir une
double nationalité il est impossible
pour les oligarques aujourd'hui d'aller
au cap d'antibes d'aller à megève ou
d'alléger une saison en france pour
jouir de leur chalet ou de leur vélo
redoux ceux qui s'amusent à suivre ces
différents yacht qui manifestement
quitte plus ou moins l'europe en tout
cas donc il ya ceux liés au temps pour
donner un exemple précis d'abramovitch
qui maintenant est en mer turque et la
turquie n'applique pas les sanctions
dont olivier d'orban qu'est ce que ça
veut dire qu'il peut effectivement aller
en turquie sur son yacht pour la russie
la turquie il n'applique pas les
sanctions mais y'a pas que la turquie on
a quasiment toute la péninsule arabique
par exemple qui n'appliquent pas non
plus les santois donc c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles les journalistes
s'y intéressent aussi énormément
d'actifs sont en transition ou ont déjà
été placées à dubaï ou dans d'autres
dans d'autres pays des émirats et pour
cette raison là parce qu'il faut aussi
penser enfin juste pour donner un tout
petit peu de contexte ces sanctions
contre les oligarques ne sont pas
nouvelles elles existent pour certains
depuis 2000 14 depuis l'annexion de la
crimée donc le gouvernement de la
lumière poutine et les oligarques se
sont aussi préparés il se serait très
naïf que de penser que les oligarques
ont attendu patiemment sans faire preuve
de ses mécanismes et d'opacité il ya
beaucoup de propriétés qui ne sont même
pas là justement justement sarah
brimbeuf vous qui êtes justement
spécialiste des flux financiers et le
fondateur par exemple j'ai vu que oleg
deripaska donc un des oligarques
fondateur de rues sales alors lui à
yacht pour revenir encore au yacht sous
pavillon de complaisance des îles
caïmans détenu par une société chypriote
elle même détenue par une société des
îles vierges britanniques
donc les européens peuvent-ils
concrètement saisir ce yacht alors on
parle de gel et c'est vrai qu'il faut
faire la visitation avec la gelée par
dont un gel sanctions politiques saisi
s'inscrit dans un cadre pénal
dans un cas de justice aux petits les
moyens en effet il faut relier les
personnes sur les listes les oligarques
et l'ensemble des personnes sur la liste
avec les biens dont ils sont
propriétaires et souvent le lien de
propriété est très détendue puisqu'il ya
un empilement de sociétés écrans de
trust souvent enregistrés dans des
juridictions offshore qui évidemment ne
transmet pas l'information donc c'est
extrêmement compliqué de perte de percer
cette opacité en pratique et pourtant on
va écouter bruno le maire qui a l'air
satisfait à lui
nous avons par exemple sur le sol bien
sur la seule question des biens
immobilisés nous avons immobilisé 22,2
milliards d'euros d'actifs de la banque
centrale russe nous avons mobilisé 150
millions d'euros de comptes de
particuliers de lignes de crédit en
france dans des établissements français
nous avons immobilisé pour 539 millions
1,2 milliard d'euros de biens
immobiliers sur le territoire français
correspondant à une trentaine de
propriétés ou d'appartements et nous
avons immobilisé deux yachts pour 150
millions d'euros au total depuis que
nous avons mis en place cette task force
pour la première fois de l'histoire du
ministère des finances qui rassemble des
centaines d'agents des services de
renseignement financier tracfin du
trésor de la douane de la direction
générale des finances publiques c'est
près d'un milliard d'euros 850 millions
d'euros très précisément qui ont été
immobilisés de bien d'avoir créé tu mens
d'oligarques ruches sur le terrain sans
plus mais 22 milliards d'euros de la
banque qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez tous
ray gerty révoltant queen
cet accord que montrent leur mère sur
les différents services
compétents visqueux track fuck serra
excusez moi il existe déjà avant et
monsieur le maire nous est gentil mais
il nous prend pour des imbéciles ce
n'est pas nouveau c'est vraiment nouveau
elle est très contente leur s compte s
que c'est efficace en fait jusqu'à ce
qu'un nouveau c'est peut-être l'ambition
politique
oui les 22 millions
j'ai une question à poser aux
spécialistes que qui me paraît important
est ce que est ce que les sanctions
telles qu'elles ont été prises
maintenant d'après ce que vous racontez
est ce qu'elles sont et compte tenu de
la fête de la façon dont les oligarques
se sont préparés à la chose est ce
qu'elles sont et ce qu'elles ont un
caractère vraiment efficace ou est-ce
que c'est plutôt de la poudre aux yeux
pour faire simple c'est m excuse
est efficace parce que et bruno le maire
a l'air de dire que c'était efficace
alors c'est
ce serait complètement naïf de penser
que ces personnes là ont besoin de ces
actifs pour exister en l'occurrence dans
l'eure dans leur mode de vie au
quotidien dans leur quotidien ça ne
change finalement pas grand chose là où
c'est assez intéressant et je comprends
dont on parle assez peu on parle
beaucoup des actifs immobiliers parce
que c'est visible et je pense qu'on est
aussi dans une logique de guerre des
images mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
aussi de dire que ces hommes et ces
femmes ont une emprise très forte sur
l'économie réelle russe et donc il ya
énormément de sociétés de très grandes
sociétés russes qui aujourd'hui se
retrouve de part leur actionnariat ou
deux dans l'impossibilité de continuer
de commercer avec l'occident est là pour
le coup c'est beaucoup plus handicapant
pour les oligarques parce que quand vous
êtes à la tête d'une société qui a fait
de la production d'acier par exemple et
que vous détenez 49% des parts et qu'on
sait très bien qu'en détenant 49 % des
parts vous allez probablement le
contrôle de ces sociétés qu'elles est
donc sanctionné vous ne pouvez plus
vendre vos produits sur le territoire
européen aux états unis et au royaume
uni et ça c'est financièrement très
handicapant et celles ci on distingue
vraiment le patrimoine personnel pour
moi là on est dans d'autres de l'ordre
du symbole et les activités aux ailes
coup là pour le coup on a quand même des
freins assez fort sachant qu'en plus ce
sont des assujettis donc sont des
banques principalement qui vérifie que
les flux entrants de ces sociétés russes
qui sont détenus ou contrôlés par de
solides marques ne ne rentre pas
effectivement sur le territoire dont il
ya une vraie un poteau qu'il yaa
un effet sur l'économie russe oui il y
est d'ailleurs on peut rajouter que les
22 milliards des avoirs de la banque
centrale russe là c'est aussi ça fait
mal parce qu'en fait c'est les réserves
financières c'est ses 22 mire uniquement
en france parce que là c'est très facile
parce que c'est déposés auprès de la
banque centrale française la plupart du
temps et dans d'autres pays c'est la
même chose ça veut dire qu'en fait
poutine avait à une cagnotte qui lui
permettait éventuellement d'amortir les
coûts les pertes économiques cette
cagnotte s'élevait à 600 600 me à 1 600
milliards de milliards d'euros est en
fait la moitié de cette cagnotte est
plus ou moins concernés par les
sanctions
internationale il reste l'autre moitié
oui l'autre moitié qui est en or donc il
faut le vendre cet or donc là aussi dont
l'excellence à ressentir
l'impact ça veut dire sans cet impact là
il ressemble beaucoup plus que les
cacahuètes de 800 parce que il faut bien
le dire 800 millions de lé gard pour
l'exercice et les cacahuètes un seuil
c'est comme si nous on sait ya c'est un
autre fait passer pour le taxi en fait
pour eux c'est sarah brown off en effet
c'est intéressant les 850 millions je
tiens à rappeler que quand bruno le
maire a annoncé la création de la task
force et une dizaine de jours il annoncé
un chiffre de mille milliards de dolla
d'euros donc présent en france où
l'union européenne s'était pas précisé
850 millions me mignard on voit qu'il ya
un énorme écart et je préciserai
également sur la première fois donc que
la task force a été créée et dont on
peut débattre sur est-ce qu'elle
existait avant ou est-ce qu'on avait les
moyens de le faire néanmoins je
préciserai que la question de l' opacité
l'empilement des sociétés écrans des
trusts etc c'est pas nouveau depuis 2000
14 depuis les révélations des panamas
peppers on ne rappelle peur cg et j'en
passe tous les ans on rappelle
l'industrie offshore la l'opacité de la
finance qui permet à ces pratiques de
prospérer une telle tu as for sale
aurait dû être créée il ya plus de dix
ans maintenant et on arrive donc sur
l'efficacité sarko en deux puis en 2008
quand il a annoncé qu'il va qu'elle
allait combattre la finance mondiale
parce que déjà ce à quoi d'ibm a voulu
pas peut-être les élus de l'église
oligarques russes mais un sarkozyste a
prononcé un discours dans lequel il
disait
l'ordre dans tout ce qui est fraude
fiscale à l'international et
ccm d'efficacité ont compris aujourd'hui
il ya véritablement un problème
d'efficacité puisqu'on n'arrive pas à
lier les noms sur les listes alors bien
on a mal on n'a pas de chiffres mais
ou l'a mal à la grosse partie de
l'iceberg il reste vraiment émergé
sachant que le chiffre est impossible
pour le groupe ce qui est assez
intéressant c'est que aucun gouvernement
aujourd'hui ne sait combien d'actifs
cédés ni par les oligarques si comme un
point assez fondamental c'est toujours
pas d'inventaire on n'a pas d'inventaire
pour les raisons d'opacité effectivement
dont on parle si révoltons une question
sur alexeï navalni un qui était
emprisonné qui a en plus pris une lourde
peine aujourd'hui 9 ans à 9 ans de
prison de plus de 9 ans dans un
communiqué l'oni pénitentiaire c'est un
régime sévère à rim cv à régime sévère
mais il ya ceux des autres régimes
passés vers lucho aussi bon il a alors
ce qui est intéressant c'est que lui il
a toujours lutté contre la corruption se
souvient des images en fait ils
parlaient de la fortune de vladimir
poutine et puis il disait d'ailleurs
qu'il fallait viser les au liban les
oligarques parce que il disait pour être
efficace de mon point de vue les
sanctions devraient viser le parti de la
guerre les oligarques les propagandistes
les dirigeants des médias et leurs
familles tous ceux qui font des grands
discours sur le monde de l'ouest à
morale mais qui vont passer le week-end
ou qui envoient leurs enfants faire
leurs études donc lui a toujours pensé
que ça serait efficace comme type de
sanction oui sans doute si elle si elle
était vraiment faim appliqué sur le long
terme avec sérieux et donc pas d'un
effet d'annonce comme on vient de le
voir avec monsieur le maire je pense
effectivement que ça peut être efficace
à long terme et fait payer le but qui
était différent un peu parce que alexeï
navalni se positionner les derniers
temps comme un homme politique est en
fait son message était adressé au peuple
russe au peuple russe qui a été spolié
de ses seins de ces sommes faramineuses
et donc en fait lui parlait plus pas de
sanction mais plus de rendre cet argent
au rouge en ago pays et du coup en fait
c'est un combat politique pour lisser
sais c'est pas forcément la même logique
dès lors quelle est la position des
oligarques sur cette guerre bat pour le
moment je crois qu'il s'en fiche un peu
mais il commence quand même à
s'inquiéter parce que
qu'on nous avait dit ils ont aussi leur
fils le souvent leurs familles qui
vivent à l'étranger pour la petite
histoire par exemple ministre des
affaires étrangères lavrov avait sa
fille sophia qu'elle lui qui qui qui
est-ce qui se prononçait contre
l'occident malheureux méchant et c est
là sa fille qui vit aux états unis en
fait ils ont tous leur famille poutine à
des deux filles qui a qui vivent à
l'étranger sa maîtresse qui
nationale la nationalité suisse enfin sa
prétendue maîtresse parce que personne
ne sait qui elle est qu'elle est
réellement d'ailleurs il ya une
actuellement une pétition circule pour
lui enlever sa nationalité suisse mais
sur la guerre en fait c'est très
difficile de rester j'ai vu que j'avais
2 qui avait passé
six qui ont commencé qui commençait à
dire en revanche c'est très haut c'était
triet yen est en fait il ya un discours
pacifiste en fait ils disent il faut
arrêter cette guerre mais c'est pas
forcément parce que il y là qu'on
condamne en fait si c'est juste parce
qu' il dise la guerre c'est mauvais ils
ne le disent pas à poutine non il a
quand même poutine a quand même demandé
l' allégeance à 2 c
il a demandé à ce qu'ils soient une
indigence pas ce serait bien ça donc ça
veut dire quand même qu'il essaye de
voir qui avec lui qui n'est pas avec lui
des hommes dans cette affaire là parce
qu'ils se doute bien quand même que dans
ce groupe dont certains sont assez
éloignées lui quand même il y en a qui
commencent à se dire ça suffit quoi
parce qu'ils vont perdre beaucoup
d'argent à cause de ce que disait ce qui
était dit sur papa sur leurs biens
personnels mais sur la base économique
shera place économique voilà ça c'est
sûr je pense pour abonder dans cette
question je pense qu'il faut vraiment
repenser la temporalité des sanctions je
pense que l'objectif qui n'est pas
affichée mais qui certainement
l'objectif poursuivi par l'union
européenne et de manière plus globale
par les démocraties occidentales qui ont
imposé ces sanctions
c'est sur le long terme d'
éventuellement faire des oligarques
empreinte bascule suis d'accord avec
vous qu'aujourd'hui les oligarques sont
bien trop dans l'ombre de l'avenir
poutine et ne peuvent absolument rien
faire sont potentiellement pour certains
risquer leur vie mais dans l'hypothèse
où les autres sanctions qui sont prises
qui touche le secteur financier qui
touche d'autres pans entiers de
l'économie ou qui touche le secteur
pétrole et gaz et au niveau américain et
canadien par exemple dans l'hypothèse en
effondrement de l'économie russe qui est
fort probable quand même au vu des
indicateurs peut-être que ces sanctions
qui crée de la frustration ces
oligarques feront d'eux le point de
bascule vraiment le moment où le chef de
la mafia assez caporal qui décident de
renverser le chef parce qu'ils ont
souffert personnellement et que le pays
souffre de venir vous y croyez sergey
zelenov qui pourrait renverser le chef
c'est impossible mais de toute façon
quand il ya quand il ya une mafia qui
existe il est le coût ne peut venir que
de l'intérieur de la matière c'est
classique et d'ailleurs même par la
télévision regardez par exemple cette
rédactrice qui a tenu sa pancarte c'est
quand même quelqu'un qui travaille elle
est donc ça veut dire qu'on savait très
bien que personne ne pouvait pénétrer
dans le studio de l'extérieur mais une
fois qu'elle est quelqu un qui al de
dell demps elle peut changer d'avis et
donc pourquoi pas même des gens qui
protège poutine ils peuvent changer
d'avis donc on vient sortir un chiffre
comme quoi les serviteurs de poutine
poutine a été servi par mille personnes
et qu'il aurait changé les derniers
temps mille personnes dans son entourage
pour ça concerne les cuisinières les
allées les personnes qui nettoie ses cd
c'est énorme palais etc parce que bien
évidemment vous supposez que et on nous
supposons tout ce qu' ils n'achètent pas
son sens à sa nourriture qui se prépare
pas à manger qu'il ne repasse pas ses
chemises etc etc donc il ya quand même
un nombre assez important en faveur des
joueurs et qu'ils puissent l'empêcher de
très près bajus trois garçons ils sont à
son contact parce que pour lui donner sa
chemise il faut convaincre
les oligarques les oligarques qu'ils ont
de l'argent puis ils ont beaucoup
d'argent et donc vous savez ce qui était
aussi une une réalité en russie c'est
qu'en fait souvent par exemple les
grands responsables du fsb du sfr de
gourou etc appartenait quasiment à un
des oligarques donc vous aviez un vice
directeur du fsb qui appartenait
abramovitch et l'autre qui a appartenait
à timchenko etc etc ce qui fait que eux
ils ont peut-être les moyens quand même
d'organiser quelques chars abrams ça
sera un petit peu l'objectif ultime si
je peux dire je sens que la théorie
qu'il puisse renverser meilleures
poutines ces oligarques
oui enfin dans un évidement enfin nous
on est moi je me prenne des associations
anti-corruption donc c'est vrai qu'on se
concentre sur qu'est-ce qu'il ya qu'est
ce qui a nourri aussi ce régime qui est
ce qui a permis de nourrir cette
influence on le lit partout il ya
énormément de sources ouvertes
énormément dans quête de journée les
investigations de rapports
parlementaires qui
décidément quelle est la religion par
les deux clientes lycées disent quoi sur
ce régime que c'est un régime corrompu
est ce qu'on pourrait dire que c'est un
état mafieux
alors
qu'à la corruption a joué un rôle on
parle de corruption stratégiques
utilisés pour asseoir une influence que
ça soit va parler par les biens mal
acquis certains sont mal à qui donc ont
été acquis avec l'argent de la
corruption et ont permis d'acheter des
villas en france placé de l'argent en
suisse etc il ya aussi les influences
dans les financements des campagnes tout
ça en parler d'influencé de corruption
stratégiques alors en effet quand on est
je reviens sur une annonce de bruno le
maire il ya quelques jours de vouloir
passer du gel au cesi et bien les
saisies s'était lancé dans un cadre
pénal un cadre de justice il a mis le
doigt sur la corruption finalement sur
la corruption qui a permis à certains
oligarques date d'acquérir leurs biens
et donc je ne préjuge pas des actions
qui seront prises mais cissé il y à il y
aura enquête pénale est donc et donc ça
pose la question de la corruption sous
toutes ses formes détournement de fonds
publics qui en tennis aveu d'oeuvre il
pourrait être condamné à un moment donné
ces oligarques et c'est possible de
condamner le blanchiment allié en france
c'est possible de condamner si on arrive
à prouver c'est extrêmement complexe
anti on arrive à prouver non seulement
le lien de propriété donc déjà la tâche
est énorme le lien propriété entre les
oligarques et les biens situés en france
et si on arrive à prouver qu'il ya eu
infraction
n'importe où dans le monde et que
l'argent qui a servi à acquérir ces
villas c'est de l'argent de la
corruption de l'argent détourné etc on
peut avoir condamnation ça s'est déjà
fait en france il vit et dort gohier des
précédents et si une approche à le dire
c'est une approche très anglo-saxonne ce
qui m'a beaucoup fait signer machecoul
dans le discours français par rapport au
discours britannique sur ce point c'est
que en france vous avez tout à fait
raison mais le doigt sans le dire sur
cette histoire de biens mal acquis ou
sur des infractions pénales qui
justifierait d'aller au delà du simple
gel et d'envisager des saisies et des
confiscations mais au royaume uni ce qui
est intéressant c'est notamment certains
de jeu constamment de chez transparency
et d'autres organisations qui luttent
contre la corruption m beaucoup plus en
avant qu'en france le fait que c'est pas
ce patrimoine s'est aussi constitué de
manière illégale cirque il est le fruit
de détournement de fonds publics il est
le fruit d'actes de corruption en retard
on se débat est beaucoup plus avancé je
trouve qu'il ne l'est en france sur la
question de savoir si on peut ou non
aller au delà et vraiment procéder à la
saisie à la vente est d'ailleurs à la
potentielle restitution soit l'état
russe soit ou éventuellement à l'ukraine
en cadres de rendre d'une réparation des
fonds qui ont été longs de déclencher
des enquêtes clairement avec le royaume
uni et sur justement le pour parler
football club justement d'abramovitch
parce que il était question de chelsea
il était question de le vendre est alors
qu'il ne peut plus vraiment le vent donc
que va-t-il se passer dans ces cas là
alors ça c'est de 13 c'était très
intéressant parce qu'en fait ça c'est à
d'ailleurs été un magnifique et ainsi de
communication politique je trouve romane
abramovitch je pense qu'on était à bout
de dix jours de guerre en ukraine
annonce de manière grand prince qu'il va
vendre son club pour reverser les trois
quatre jeux puis quelle est la position
de milliards de deux parades à l'ukraine
un fonds qui permettra d'aider la
construction faut savoir que roman
abramovitch a lutté et a fait un lobby
excessivement intense auprès des
autorités britanniques pour et des
autorités européennes pour ne pas être
lisse et romain d'avoir un budget a été
listé on a été placé chez disent qu'il
n'y a que quelques jours et donc de
manière très cynique la 7,77 vente
annoncée était vraiment un moyen pour
lui de chercher une forme de génie thé
et de se faire blanchir par les
autorités européennes et britanniques
pour ne pas peser sur ces lycées pour ne
pas perdre la jouissance de ses autres
biens il est sur la liste est ce qui
peut vendre ce club il ne peut plus
vendre ce qu'elle ne peut plus vendre
ces clubs la pénétration des oligarques
dans le but en angleterre est beaucoup
plus importante que les bien sûr c'est
le tapis rouge c'est ça les allemands il
y en a qui ont été faits pères et s'est
donc élevé le parti et le parti
conservateur n'est pas très blanc blanc
dans tout ça si je puis dire après en
france il ya aussi
il ya eu des légions d'honneur il ya eu
ce même les des hommes politiques
français pour ne pas le nommer à
françois fillon qui était dans le
conseil d'administration qui dao sauce
empressé de quitter ces deux postes que
poutine lui a offert
donc mais avant ils étaient très
contents car inc nice on triche c'est
pareil
j'adore ça c'est l'exemple type enfin de
lui il est là depuis 20 ans il cumule
tous les postes en fait elle est très
cynique ces panneaux les gars que
ces sanctions peuvent être dissuadés
vladmir poutine de poursuivre la guerre
ça là je peux pas y répondre à cette
question simplement parce que je n'ai
pas calé qu'est ce qu'elle a dans la
tête de poutine en vérité vous savez on
le sait donc c'est très compliqué a
priori ça dépend bon il faut déplacer un
peu le sujet pour qu'on arrive à
comprendre mais enfin c'est moi c'est
mon opinion ce que j'ai pu j'ai exprimé
là donc je pense que poutine a raté son
coup si je puis dire le dit on le sait
je veux dire il pensait qu'en trois
jours ça serait réglé il est enlisé il
ya des problèmes il est père des
généraux ce qui est quand même mauvais
signe ah ça veut dire que je ne vous
savez que c'est pourquoi c'est mauvais
signe que c'est vrai que les généraux
sont allées sont obligés d'aller en
première ligne alors on va faire bouger
les gens donc ça veut dire tout ça il
est dans une situation et le dégel un
matériel j'attends donc tout ça ce sont
des situations qui sont excessivement
sont pas bonnes du tout donc de toutes
façons soit il va vraiment il joue son
va-tout il va en avant avec tous les
risques que peut représenter soit ils
essaient de trouver un compromis
visiblement on essaye aujourd'hui
d'arriver à un compromis qui soulagera
hier tout le monde y compris des
ukrainiens bien sûr car elle arrête pas
de se recevoir des bombes mais aussi les
occidentaux qu'ils seront contents qu'un
que tout ça s'arrête et et poutine qui
aura l'impression d'avoir remporté une
semi-victoire alors c'est plutôt une
famille des fêtes bon donc tout ça c'est
plutôt que tel à cet ordre là que ça se
joue à mon avis ça se joue pas beaucoup
pour l'instant sur le temps dans ce
temps là je veux dire qui est assez
court maintenant sur six mois alors oui
bien sûr ça peut jouer considérablement
bien sûr compte tenu de ce qui a été dit
par olivier damgan par exemple
il peut effectivement ça peut avoir un
effet sur la guerre ces sanctions
s'appelle dissuader de la poursuivre
quand on les oligarques non je ne crois
pas parce que c'est plus du goût du côté
symbolique en fait c'est l'essai sont
des sanctions symboliques vous continuez
à dire que c'est symbolique alors qu'on
parle comme d'impact sur l'économie
l'économie c'est autre chose en fait il
faut rappeler que la russie c'est un
tout petit pays économiquement c'est un
pays qui produit justement entre
portugal et l'espagne et qui dépend
entièrement presque entièrement 89% à
l'exportation et l'importation du marché
international dont qu'on fait c'est un
pays qui est très facile ou fêtard a
bloqué mais voilà on bloque pas les les
avoirs désolé garp on bloque les
produits russes et ont sorti de ce we
lost a quand même les entreprises qui
sont détenus parce que ça reste quand
même une économie qui est aussi assez
peu finalement diversifié il ya une
poignée d'hommes et de femmes détiennent
dans ce sens là oui dans celui-ci sont
sortis de ce oui en tout cas en partie
donc pensez pas que ça peut te dit ce
message non mais de toute façon toujours
quand quand vous avez ça en revanche je
suis d'accord poutine déjà est ce qu'il
s'est dit lui même ce qu'il veut parce
que j'ai l'impression à m'ont donné que
pour moi à partir de 21 février il a
commis que dès que des fautes des fautes
militaire stratégique économique en fait
tout tout tout ce qui toutes les
décisions que poutine prend depuis un
mois pour moi c'est laisser les fautes
il se mit il s'est mis tout le tout la
communauté internationale sur le dos il
a violé la charte des nations unies la
violer la vague n'a pas encore perdu la
guerre aux îles
il a perdu la guerre parce qu'en fait
elle que croyait avoir vaincu de cette
guerre en trois jours et cette guerre
n'a hélas perdue d'un côté et or il ya
autre chose aussi c'est que je vous
assure qu'il ne pourra jamais dominé les
45 millions de nos yeux d'ukrainiens il
peut les mettre à feu et à sang mais il
gagnera jamais cette guerre il peut
finir devant le tribunal appréhension de
la et olivier daures grands criminels de
guerre un mot c'est à dire poutine
justement sur est-ce qu'on peut
s'attaquer à la fortune de lanières
poutine est ce que ça fait partie des
sanctions
la poutine fait l'objet de mesures de
gel des avoirs mais alors je pense qu'en
terme d'opacité dont on parle quand même
depuis un certain temps sur ce plateau
je pense que l'opacité de la fortune de
la lumière poutine c'est potentiellement
la reine de toutes les eaux des trocs
niveau détrompez vous non on pensait
aussi tout ça et bah non par exemple on
a en a trouvé un yacht oui dans lequel
comme par hasard tous les gens qui
travaillaient sur le luxueux yacht
appartenait aux filles service fédéral
de sécurité et donc du coup on dit que
ce yacht c'est celui de poutine mais
ollier d'orgue en voiture on est sûr de
sympa lui on en est quand même laisser
le temps à me dire que sur les sur les
actifs financiers de la démarche hawtin
sas et je vais quiconque autour de cette
table de dire vers quelle est la fortune
l'a dit mercredi et un chiffre a été
annoncé j'ai pas s'il est vrai enfin de
200 milliards de dollars la rentrée un
autre chiffre 400 millions et d'autres
personnes donc fait c'est bien c'est ce
que dit olivier d'orgon c'est à dire
atout pour ce pour toutes les échelles
poutine pour que les sanctions contre la
demi-heure poutine soit efficace
personnellement il faudrait qu'on sache
déjà ce que détient au delà des mers
poutine est ouest la villardière à
biarritz en l'occurrence c'est quelque
chose mais c'est intéressant de regarder
parce qu'il ya une obligation en russie
de déclarer les avoirs qu'on a lorsqu'on
est indécis d un décideur public poutine
il y ait un ce train il ya deux
appartements à sa performance et une ou
deux voitures il n'y a pas grand chose
et je c'est vrai que si on fait le test
aujourd'hui il ya un registre en france
des de savoir qui à qui appartient quoi
qu'ils sont les derniers qui sont
derrière les sociétés qui toutes les
sociétés si vous tapez le nom de
vladimir poutine vous trouverez rien
certains oligarques ont quand même
rempli leur déclaration on peut trouver
alors malheureusement c'est pas la
majorité mais on peut trouver on peut
relier certains certains de ses biens et
c'est ce qu'a fait bercy en annonçant
ces mesures ollier d'aurier à un exode
aujourd'hui des oligarques verts
justement ces pays neutres comme dubaï
ravi de voir que des journalistes
d'investigation s'intéresse à ça je sais
que notamment le monde avec un
consortium de l'analyse travaille
activement en ce moment a justement
tracé des actifs il faut quand même un
point qu'on n'a pas du tout évoqué ce
soir c'est pourquoi est ce que les
oligarques ont aussi massivement investi
en europe et les oliviers et une
appétence quand même à la conso moy de
consommation mode de vie occidental de
l'humain et ça on en a parlé en fil
rouge mais on n'a pas vraiment dit et je
pense que quand on apprécie aussi la
portée de ces sanctions il faut aussi
dire que ces personnes là on va leur
interdire de vivre en mode de vie qui
n'ont pas connu avant la chute de l'urss
qui l'ont découvert et qu'ils ont
apprécié dont ils veulent faire
bénéficier leurs enfants et qui
aujourd'hui leur est interdit donc oui
dubaï est une alternative comme d'autres
endroits dans la péninsule arabique mais
pour autant ça ne remplacera jamais le
londres-paris aux yeux des oligarques et
d'ailleurs poutine s'est s'est joint à
ces fonds que ces sentiers ou parce
qu'il a prononcé un discours dans lequel
il disait ces gens là qui ont un look
très l'habitude de boire du champagne de
manger du foie gras donc en fait ce sont
les traîtres donc ils sont séparés du
peuple et donc du coup il les oblige
maintenant de rentrer au bercail et bas
il y en a beaucoup qui vont être déçus
impasse que courchevel changé entre
courchevel et moscou
des fois pour les gens qui ont des
moyens basse ça change du tout au tout
c'est révoltant je voulais dire je vais
faire une aparté un peu ailleurs c'est
que ce qui se passe sur
crédits sur sur l'appétence des ddd
russe riche pour le vrai monde
occidental on trouve également la même
chose en chine et je veux dire c'est
exactement la même chose c'est-à-dire
que les chinois vis rejet par la haute
direction chinoise non mais c'est vrai
qu'ils qui est aussi complètement
impliqué dans notre monde et et ne rêve
que tous les lits tous les enfants des
dirigeants chinois sont harvard et
stanford et c'est accepter par exemple
pour rebondir en effet on parle des
chinois mais en fait les pratiques la
l'appétence pour le mode de vie
occidental quasiment tous les dirigeants
étrangers corrompus les kleptocrates
pour reprendre une terminologie
anglo-saxonne on utilise les mêmes
procédés l'empilement de sociétés-écrans
l'organisation d'opacité pour évidemment
pas profiter de ces modes de vie en
ayant le plus de distance par rapport à
leur bien et on parlait qui va gagner la
guerre personne ne le sait mais en tout
cas la question se pose aujourd'hui sur
les oligarques russes on voit que les
sanctions sont des annonces pour
l'instant elles sont elles sont pas
elles sont peu effectif peu efficace se
pose la question finalement de la lutte
contre les flux financiers illicites
parce que c'est le problème de fond
s'est produite et contrôlés contre
l'opacité contre les sociétés écrans
contre les juridictions offshore tout ça
bien on a manqué le coche depuis des
années finalement malgré certains
sursaut venant de l'union européenne
notamment aujourd'hui peut-être qu'il ya
un moment pour la france pour les pays
de l'union européenne pour les
démocraties occidentales véritablement
de s'attaquer au fond de ce problème ça
nécessite des moyens financiers ça
nécessite de renforcer les outils
existants et c'est vraiment le moment on
voi pour l'instant vous dites les
sanctions sont pas effectives en tout
cas c'est
efficace alors effectivement ce qui a
été dit mais elles tendent un petit peu
à côté sur de la cible en termes de
chiffres c'est certain et elles sont là
et peut-être parce qu'on a parlé de la
fin de la guerre moi ce qui m'intéresse
aujourd'hui c'est la temporalité je
reviens toujours à cette nation laissant
ici ça serait complètement illusoire que
de penser que si demain il ya un
cessez-le-feu et que ce cessez-le-feu
respecté les sanctions seraient
immédiatement levé donné dans une
temporalité je le rappelle on a des
sanctions contre la russie comme été
prise dès 2014 qui sont toujours en
justement quand vous dites sanctions
quand on est la risée 2014 et ils ont
réussi justement à les contourner à ces
oligarques qui ont été sanctionnés bah
non pas vraiment
c'est un autre débat parce qu'en fait
des sanctions contre la russie 2014 à le
viser des oligarques mais elle vise
aussi le secteur de l'énergie et la
russie a pris un retard considérable en
termes d'avancées technologiques on aura
pas ce débat ce soir et il les sanctions
2014 parce qu'elles ont notamment rompu
des partenariats par exemple entre exxon
et rosneft est en retard monstrueux qui
a été pris par la russie en termes de
d'exploration et de capacité de
production de ses propres ressources
naturelles du fait des sanctions c'est
moins visible c'est beaucoup moins ça
parle beaucoup moins en terme de la
guerre des images mais les sanctions
2014 ont été efficaces sur le
développement économique de la russie
donc ça peut durer en fait hein c'est ce
qu'a dit peut-être peut-être qu'à dans
le mauvais il ya peut-être du bon ça
veut dire que regarder par exemple
poutine il a réussi à réunir l'europe et
le monde occidental comme jamais
l'europe n'a été émis et peut-être ça ça
va reposer la même question que c'est
pour ça je vous ai rappelé déjà sarkozy
a dit oui le mot de financer faudra
lutter contre les trucs opaque et c'est
luxembourg parce que les paradis fiscaux
c'est pas à l'autre bout de la planète 1
c en france vous avez vous avez à côté
de noms mais s'il a des bases et garder
basaraba
phocéen monaco ils sont autour de vous
donc en fait vous faut pas aller très
loin ceux pour lesquels jacques robert
on va dire là quelques progrès
évidemment si on compare le dispositif d
de la france en matière de lutte anti
blanchiment aujourd'hui il n'a plus rien
à voir avec celui qui dit qu'il y
existait il ya 15 ans et certains
néanmoins on a encore d'énormes trous
dans la raquette et on a aussi un manque
crucial de moyens c'est à dire qu'en
fait si on demande la transparence il
faut pouvoir gérer la transparence
analyser les données qu'on va vous
donner sa demande des moyens d à des
agents publics finalement on a annoncé
une task force de sang une centaine
d'agents est ce qu'elle sera pérennisée
est-ce que ce dialogue entre bercy entre
la chancellerie sera pérennisé est ce
qu'on aura une véritable politique de
lutte anti blanchiment de lutte
anticorruption pas seulement contre
isoler les oligarques mai contre
l'ensemble des flux financiers illicites
qui atterrissent d'une manière ou d'une
autre en france aujourd'hui un mot
peut-être justement sur le fait qu'il
soit sorti de swift est ce que ça
contribue olivier doran justement à
faire que ces sanctions soient
extrêmement forte il ya un lien tout de
même parce qu'on parle flux financiers
ça lancement des entreprises jeu juste
un petit peu minimisé la portée de cette
mesure alors c'est une mesure qui vient
isoler le système bancaire russe et
paradoxalement pour aller dans ce sens
de ce qui est dit en matière de
transparence n'est pas forcément une
très bonne nouvelle ce que la russie a
développé un canal alternatif à swift le
spf est ce la chine également un cas
d'insuffisance et canal oui ce qu'il
soit suffisant ou non le risque est
d'ailleurs c'est une des hésitations
américaines tout début de tout début de
la guerre c'est est ce que finalement on
ne va pas swift permet d'avoir une
certaine mainmise des états sur les flux
financiers les américains ne l'avoueront
jamais mais swift est une organisation
qui est certes indépendante mais qui
peut collaborer quand on en juin avec
des autos donc l'iphone est sous
contrôle merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous thierry wolton
merci à vous merci saga dire non merci à
vous l'idée dorgans merci sarah brown et
puis merci à vous tous nous arriver
reste avec nous en france à 4